hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm just checking in
on you
just checking in on you to see how you
doing i just had a smoothie for dinner
oh boy
exciting
i had a [ __ ] smoothie for dinner and
uh
i don't think i made it right it tastes
weird i could taste what it was trying
to be
and then i looked at the ingredients and
i realized that i [ __ ] it up
um
the hell was it here
it was i'll tell you the recipe
i got it on christine's chicken no
kristen's
kristen's kitchen
christine's chicken see this is why i
did bad to school like i have some
[ __ ]
undiagnosed uh
dyslexia or i'm just stupid kristen's
kitchen became christine's chicken
um
a cocoa almond protein smoothie
three quarters a cup of greek yogurt a
half a cup plus two tablespoons of milk
i didn't see the two tablespoons of milk
i just did a quarter of a cup of milk
one medium banana sliced preferably
frozen
half a tablespoon of unsweetened cocoa
powder two tablespoons almond butter two
teaspoons of ground flax seed that's
optional
and three quarters of cup ice
of ice cubes
i should say three quarters of a cup um
jesus christ i don't know what i did
wrong with that but it did not look like
the one that they made
because you know what they did was after
they made it they then put a little they
put like three banana slices on top and
then they they crumpled some dark
chocolate on top of it you're like what
the [ __ ] is that and then you look at
yours after you get done making it it
just looks like you know
somebody shouldn't have drank the water
but it tasted good
and i'm hanging in there
you know i had an acting gig today you
know and i had you know low budget
things so i had to bring my own costume
as they say my own wardrobe and i
grabbed some slacks
and a shirt and um
it ended up being uh
you know from my skinny days and i was
able to fit i had to squeeze in but i
was able to fit so i'm getting back
all right i feel like i'm past the
halfway point
and uh
you know
i'm sticking with this [ __ ] although
i am going back east coming up to
foxwood so that might be a bad couple of
days
um but i don't know what i'll do i'll
find an elliptical somewhere or i'll do
something
i'll do something i'll i will figure out
something but uh i've had a really
really really good week i had such a
good time uh on that acting gig today
and uh
you know i had to play you know like i
said i only had a couple of lines
playing this little character and what's
great though is uh
when you have a shaved head
you know
and then you shave your beard off
like the
like the hair person now has a complete
blank slate to work with and they can
just
age you make you younger whatever and we
just had a [ __ ] blast today
and uh i came out i didn't even people
didn't even know it was me
it was so much [ __ ] fun so much fun
all right so that's for all you young
actors out there all right if you're
[ __ ] unsightly like myself and you're
losing your hair just know you know
there's so much fun to be have
still you know it's okay if you don't
look like brad pitt you could look like
me and still get [ __ ] work and then
just steer in to how [ __ ] up you look
and then it just becomes uh like the
best time ever and that's what i did
so we shot today um at this location the
guy who let us in
he had what looked like a harley road
king but it had like the windscreen and
the radio and all of that on it
and oh did i get the motorcycle bug
oh my god did i get the motorcycle bug
once in your life if you're an american
you got to ride a [ __ ] road king you
just have to do it
um
so
i don't know i just
he turned it on
that thing [ __ ] that engine that v
twin whatever the [ __ ] they call it i
was just like i i i want one of those
i didn't want one and then i saw yours
and i heard it and now i want it you
know
that's how it works
it's basically
how it works so um but anyway we uh did
the acting gig and everybody i was
working with was fun
director was awesome and it was a really
fun project and uh you know got in and
out of there in like a half a day
i mean actually the longest thing was
the hair and the makeup
peel that [ __ ] off me afterwards or the
makeup lady doing it
um
and she did a great job too i'll tell
you underrated underrated if you're
acting and they put a bunch of stuff on
you at the end of the day if the makeup
person actually hangs around
and gives you the right products to get
all of that extra [ __ ] off of your face
is incredible because there's some
people i've worked with in like a week
after i've wrapped on the gig
you know
i'll just scratch behind my ear and
there's still glue or something
something stuck there that it's like
invisible you can't see it
and you gotta have some oil-based thing
to get it off and then finally it just
starts looking like like what is that
is that an old age spot and you realize
it's this is gross it's like [ __ ] old
glue maybe not a week later but like a
day or two later it's just [ __ ] like
you just feel like you can't get clean
so
anyway shout out to my boston red sox
who i've been watching for the last uh
five games including tonight of course i
sit down on the you know
bill oh billy the mush you know i
watched him lose four straight games get
swept by the uh the devil rays i watched
that whole series and i watched him lose
the first of a three game set against
the uh the detroit tigers
yeah but tonight they won
and i hit a couple of home runs and [ __ ]
getting to know the team you know
getting caught up getting ready for
[ __ ] october baseball and everything
and um
love and listen to eckersley in his own
language
you know it's just fun listen to that
guy call the game and everything um
i always think it's great when there's a
pitcher in the booth
because uh
i don't know i just feel like with
hitters you can kind of see what they're
doing but like he's always calling the
pitchers and gets guessing the pitches
and saying why the guy did it or blah
blah blah blah or
what he should have done and all of that
i [ __ ] love it man really uh
enjoyable um
shout out to the los angeles lakers
uh jesus christ
[Laughter]
putting together a boy band out there my
god
they already bought a title two [ __ ]
years ago right
they buy lebron because they know that
he's like a [ __ ] he's like a uh
what do you call that's like a
cornerstone and then all the [ __ ]
free agents will flutter over to him
like a moth to a light and they get
anthony davis right [ __ ] new orleans
those people they don't they don't
deserve anything do they
it's just new orleans
they're just americans why should they
enjoy an nba title why should they have
anthony davis and zion right [ __ ] it go
ahead see ya he goes to there and they
buy a [ __ ] title
um
oh my god i was [ __ ] teasing laker
fans on twitter jesus christ and then
they [ __ ] uh they all took the bait
and none of them could defend them
buying a title oh they keep saying you
mad bro
don't be sad why you hating
that's the intellect of a lycra fan but
what else they gonna say they should
just admit it yeah we're buying titles
why i do it we bought one in 2008 the
celtics bought a [ __ ] title that was
a [ __ ] pylon championship there you
go and we and but you know what we only
we only need two we only needed two free
agents
unlike these [ __ ]
then they had uh [ __ ] uh what's his
face tim witherspoon there uh westbrook
then they had him right there here we go
again
and then i don't know what i guess they
were watching an episode of the golden
girls so they signed [ __ ] carmelo
anthony
all right
oh my god he's he's an all-defensive
player
okay
um and then today they got for like the
third [ __ ] time
dwight howard
i think the lakers are just for some
reason it just bothered them
that this [ __ ] adonis
could not win a ring with them they just
have to [ __ ] get this guy a goddamn
ring
um
but that is you know i guess it's it's
consistent with the lakers they've
always bought other people's stars
it's just what they do that's what they
do they're mount rushmore they always
talk about all the great centers centers
in [ __ ] la laker history and none of
them
none of them unless you go back to world
war ii and find the white guy george
mike and that was in minneapolis but
there's not one
hall of fame
center
in the los angeles lakers history that
was a drafted los angeles laker they
cannot pick a [ __ ] center to save
their [ __ ] lives
so they got to take out the checkbook
and buy wilt and buy kareem and buy shaq
and buy anthony davis they just got to
buy the guys
ugh
which i guess is fine because that's how
they [ __ ] do it now but like for them
to just sit there oh you know kobe's got
five titles he's only one behind [ __ ]
george like jordan didn't get a boatload
of free agent help every [ __ ] year
it's not the same thing
you could say he's got five and jordan
has six but don't act like it's the same
level of difficulty because it isn't
it isn't
jordan did not play in a [ __ ] era
where everybody was friends and sat on a
[ __ ] boat and just hey let's all jump
on this team and we're going to oh okay
hey now everybody we're jumping on this
team
i don't know i'm just going to keep
saying it because he's [ __ ] like it
drives some [ __ ] bananas
if it wasn't for the rest of the league
drafting the right people and developing
the talent the lakers could never win a
title
[Laughter]
yeah and i love these lakers fans that
try to act like the kobe shack er it
wasn't a pylon [ __ ] team
with phil jackson and you can totally
tell it was a pylon team because when
shaq got sick of kobe goes i [ __ ] you
i'll go play with dwayne wade and then
they won
bam
i can win with you or i can win with you
i'll either pile on here or i'll [ __ ]
pile on there um all right i'm done with
that [ __ ] um anyway let's talk about uh
i want to start an open dialogue with
anybody who who listens to this podcast
who rides a bike bicycle in the city
and as someone who drives a car just out
of curiosity what the [ __ ]
is your guy's problems
like i just want to hear what is the
[ __ ] problem
like they're [ __ ] the most arrogant
[ __ ] [ __ ]
only a person on a bike can be breaking
a law while yelling at somebody in a car
for doing the same thing it's literally
what happened to me right i was [ __ ]
late i went down to side street i did a
rolling stop through a stop sign as a
guy in a bicycle is also not stopping at
a stop sign and then he looks at me and
gives me a sarcastic thumbs up
like he's [ __ ] dudley do right and i
was late i just wanted to back up and be
like dude
you know you're required
to follow the rules of the road for some
reason people on bicycles think they're
above stopping at red lights or maybe
because you have your little lance
armstrong [ __ ] slippers on
as you pretend to be in the tour de
france
riding down the street you don't want to
take them out so you just blow through a
red light
i mean if they obeyed the rules of the
road i don't i don't hate everybody on a
bicycle when i see somebody in street
clothes on a bicycle with just a helmet
on they're always a good [ __ ] they
always get over they let you get by but
the second they put on like the [ __ ]
the the i don't know
the the laker girl wear you know with
all the advertisement on it like they're
in some sort of time trial
the second they do that [ __ ] they just
become these [ __ ] who ride out in the
middle of the street with what's with
wha it looks like a funeral procession
is behind them
i just love how they always shake their
head
when something after they [ __ ] blow
through a red light and they almost get
hit then they shake their head
and it's just like buddy you're riding a
bicycle in a city
what do you think is gonna have what are
you shaking your head about
that you can't believe that what
everybody knows is gonna happen happened
riding out in the road i love those guys
they think they're going as fast as a
car
and they start riding out in the [ __ ]
road like they're like they're uh i
don't know in that movie quick silver
um
and then we got a thing out here what
happens to you guys like all of a sudden
like
20 of these people all dressed like
[ __ ] you know greg lamond right
get out there and they just decide to
have
a you know a practice bike race
and there's all of this traffic behind
them
and they're just laughing going down the
street it's not even a bike lane they
just took over a [ __ ] lane
they're just like they're just [ __ ]
they really are they're [ __ ]
is just my opinion as someone in a car
now i would just like to hear your
perspective i want you guys to write in
okay and i want you to be honest with me
the percentage of time that you actually
obey the rules of the road and actually
be honest with me if you even knew that
that was a [ __ ] rule
if you're even aware of that you have to
do like the same i have to stop at a
stop sign i got to stop at a [ __ ] red
light
right
you do too
which is why
if i coast through a stop sign and you
coast through a stop sign don't shake
your little helmeted head at me
all right if you came to a complete stop
it wouldn't have been a [ __ ] problem
but you rolled through it too like a
dumb ass
i'm rolling through in a car i'm fine i
got [ __ ] airbags your dumb ass is on
a [ __ ] bicycle
all right
i don't know maybe they want to be
martyrs maybe they want to get [ __ ]
hit you know so they can have their bike
frosted and they can live forever on
that bike lane in the sky
is that what it is
are they environmentalists is that why
you do it
i'm not putting gas in the air you know
whatever fumes in the air i guess you're
doing that that's a positive but then
you buy like 20 of those little biking
outfits you know and you're going to
sweat through them and just throw them
out they're going to end up in the
[ __ ] ocean so i don't know
where does that take you
you little dumb dancing slippers
they're never in a race but they're
always dressed like they are
you know
that's like the guy back in the day if
you played like pick up football and he
showed up wearing cleats
it's like oh god
not this guy
um
sorry i am just extra [ __ ] today i'm
just a little tired that's all it is uh
i'm psyched the red sox one i don't give
a [ __ ] about the lakers i just i just
really like stirring them up because
i've discovered that so few of them can
even talk the game and i don't even know
that much
about basketball but like all they have
is
why you mad
why are you crying why you hating that's
all they can say
ah they're dumb
they're just dumb
um anyways
let's move on let's move on to some i
don't need this [ __ ] why am i doing this
you don't provoke los angeles fans they
can't talk the game so then they get
scared and then they stab you
you know they want to win the argument
um all right
let's do a little uh
let's do a little advertising here oh
it's helix everybody
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot gross
mattresses for great great for spinal
alignment
what do they put you on a rotisserie
uh to prevent morning aches and pains
i've never heard of that that's amazing
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers
for all the big boys out there
the quarter pounders were cheesy
uh so if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you match to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again you don't ever need to go to
a mattress store again they wrote it
twice
just in case you went what
i said you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again helix is awesome
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 and by gq
and wired magazine helix has been
has been commended we got a typo here
it's been
commended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine
doctors of sleep medicine like bill
cosby doctors of sleep medicine are like
i'm having problems sleeping it's got to
be that one
doesn't say i know cosby got out but
jesus the advertisers went to him pretty
quick there as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life and i got to
tell you this as you get older
i mean underrated man just having a
mattress where you just sleep like a
baby you can't put a price on that
you know parents out there if you got
kids you just want to hit the [ __ ]
sack
and wake up feeling refreshed
um they have a 10-year warranty and you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it gross
but you will helix has even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helixsleep.com
for up to 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows
i mean you can't beat that can you
you can't beat that couple of free
pillows with your goddamn mattress
um
anyway
i've been swimming all this week trying
to do something else you know keep the
shoulder going i had a little bit of a
setback with it i'm such a [ __ ] idiot
such an idiot it was something heavy and
i was like don't pick that up and i
[ __ ] picked it up you know and then i
realized i didn't want that i moved it
over another thing i felt a little
twinged i'm like i'm fine i just keep
having setbacks
you know i gotta like i gotta like
finally like push through but i i think
i think my arm feels pretty good but i
just been sort of doing pool
because you got like the anti-gravity
thing i've been in the pool like four or
five days in a row
and
um you know my shoulder was doing pretty
good until i watched the olympics and
then i tried to i always every time the
olympics comes around once every four
years i watch the summer olympics and i
say to myself you know i could do the
butterfly stroke
i'm 53 with a bad shoulder why don't i
try that out in the middle of rehab
let's see how that does for me
just a [ __ ] right
[ __ ] stupid so anyway speaking of the
red sox i believe
i believe
monday morning podcast guests
wolfgang wolfgang van halen with mammoth
open for guns and roses last night
well that would be tuesday night
if you guys listen on thursday
tuesday night at fenway park man i would
have loved to have seen that show
that sounds like that's going to be an
amazing tour
uh word to the grapevine is guns and
roses sounds uh
better than um
better than they ever have which is an
unbelievable statement
and uh i got to see mammoth
kind of run through this set
right before they went out i got to
stand there like the little fanboy that
i am and they sounded [ __ ]
unbelievable
so um if you guys are out there and
you're going crazy and you're looking
for something to do get a ticket to that
if it's not all sold out because that is
a
that is a great great great lineup
obviously legendary guns and roses and
then
uh mammoth coming up here the great
album by the way you should check out
um
so with that speaking of that let's talk
you guys let's talk dad drummond
everybody
let's talk dad drummer because i haven't
been you know i tried was flying the
other day and
you know flying some approaches and my
stupid glide slope wasn't working and
all of that so i think i need a new
antenna
on uh
on the helicopter but uh
i don't know that's every time i start
getting close then i either i go away
for a few weeks i'm really just when i
get back i'm just gonna have to just
buckle down and start just fly two a
days
for a couple of weeks just clear my
schedule and then i'll be ready to go
because i know i'll pass the oral exam
i've been just every day when i get on
the elliptical i just look like look at
another chapter with my flash cards
and just blow through it and uh i don't
know no matter what happens i became a
way better pilot way more informed i
know i'm gonna get this rating i don't
know when because i have been really uh
really busy and um
but i've just been having um
you know when you just sort of fly and
you just fly like visual all the time as
far as your avionics like i feel like
you're only using like half
the machine
and then when you go for like the
instrument rating it's just like this
whole other world that was like right in
front of you
um the helicopter i fly has like a uh
glass cockpit
meaning it doesn't have like the analog
gauges and stuff which is something i've
always liked analog gauges but now i'm
so kind of sold
on the glass card pick now that i know
where to look and everything and my scan
has been really good
um
and i don't know i just been flying
really well lately and uh
this [ __ ] antenna thing came up and
now i'm gonna be going back east for a
little bit so i was getting a little
bummed out but i was just like i'm gonna
get it i'm gonna get it i got until
december
i'm feeling like i'm pretty close and i
just feel like if i just did like you
know if i flew like
five days a week two two weeks in a row
just doubled down
flew twice a day with two different
instructors
um
i think that that's what i'm gonna do
you know because now i know what to do i
know how to talk on the radio throughout
the whole approach
i can do the whole [ __ ] thing i know
what how to dial everything in i just
need to do it like a thousand times over
two weeks and then i can get it that's
my game plan that it's the game plan
all right and then i'll i don't then i
know i don't know what's going to happen
because right around the time i get that
we'll be rapping
not only on this season of efforts for
family but just the season it the whole
show is just going to be done
and i'm gonna have a lot of free time
and
my plan is
to not fill that up with work
i would really like to uh
kind of slow it down a little bit just
hang out you know with the family
and friends or whatever and uh
you know be old billy behind the scenes
okay you come to me with the show idea
we sell it and then i'm [ __ ] behind
the scenes you you go do all this [ __ ]
all right
i just want to [ __ ] chill out man
i've been playing a lot of drums lately
i found this really great
sort of like uh this guy on instagram
it's almost like you're playing just
like song enders
with like 16th note triplets and it's
just four different groupings of it
and i've just been getting those things
up to speed and one of them is just
a right hand followed by a double kick
um
which is you know the bottom lick from
good times bad times so i'm sort of
practicing that without even playing the
song just by doing these
as like a warm up and uh
so i play it to like a quarter note
so i'm really playing triplets not 16th
note triplets even though my brain is
thinking of them and 16th no triplets
they're really just more like uh
groupings of six that i'm playing
you know over
two quarter notes so it becomes triplets
but the phrasing that this guy was
playing him in was in 16th note triplets
so
um i've been doing that so on the
quarter note
on the uh on the click i've gotten up to
like
bpms which you know if i was doing an
eighth note thing is like 85 bpms good
times bad times it's 95 bpms so i've
kind of been like right there i'm just
like i'm just going to keep [ __ ]
doing this
before i even practice that it'll be
like you know doing like an extra
workout and it's also something i've
been i've always been amazed that people
that could just sit down at drums
and just sort of be free and then
they're not just sitting there playing
licks
which is what i'm doing right now
they're actually listening to what
they're playing which makes them try to
play something else i want to like kind
of i've been trying to delve into that
area
for a while now once i realized that
that existed and that's what all these
great drummers that i loved
that
you know you couldn't take your eyes off
them you know as much as you know you go
to like back in the day i would go to
like these drum clinics and [ __ ] i
[ __ ] saw everybody
you know i go down to berkeley or i go
to a jazz club i [ __ ] saw so many
legendary drums and there was just
certain drummers that you went to and i
went to like a modern drummer clinic one
time the things that they have out in
jersey
and um
i just noticed that there was some
people they were all playing 90 million
everybody could play 90 million miles an
hour but there was some people that
could do it in a way
that
it made you want to
be able to do what they were doing you
just it just drew you in
like what are they doing
that is any different than this other
person and it's um
i think it's
like most performance that they're
present they're listening to what
they're playing they have an idea of
what they want to do and if some and if
a new idea pops into their head they
have the ability
to express it and because they're in the
moment
there's there's an adrenaline rush to
that to the performer and there's an
excitement that they're getting which
the audience i think subconsciously
picks up on and then you're drawn to
what they're playing as opposed to
somebody who already has the whole
[ __ ] thing worked out
you know
and it's just sitting there just plain
licks around the kit which is something
that i do and i have a look on my face
by the way like i'm waiting for a bus so
that's another thing that just is you
know there's a lot of holes in my plank
that's all i'm saying
so
anyway it's like 8 30 right now and i
got the kids in bed and everything so
that's probably what i'm gonna be going
down there to do so whatever um you know
i keep trying
i keep trying to stop bitching
about you know
over the years the golden state warriors
with kd the brooklyn nets the [ __ ]
lakers every other year and all of that
[ __ ]
i i i know you guys are sick of me i'm
getting sick of talking about it but
like
it just drives me nuts because i'll put
on espn thinking this has got to be
finally they added too many free agents
finally and espn somebody's gonna say
something and they never do they just
act like it isn't happening
they act like it's good for the [ __ ]
league i guess it's good for them
maybe because people watch pylon teams
i don't know maybe that maybe they're
actually better ratings i don't know
maybe it's got it always comes down to
money
but uh i don't know i just find them
excruciatingly boring and i don't like
watching them and i just i think they're
[ __ ] championships they just are
all right
grow a dick and lead a team
instead of [ __ ] buying up everybody
that you would have had to lead them
past they're now on your [ __ ] team
it's just [ __ ] it's
that's not it's not sports
what is this [ __ ] ocean's 11 of the
[ __ ] basketball team all right i'm
done sorry i'm getting going again
dude me bitching about the [ __ ] nba
pylon teams it's like the end of lenny
bruce's career when he stopped being
funny and he just kept looking at his
[ __ ] legal pad
i'm not saying he wasn't funny i think
he was still funny but he would just
[ __ ] talk about what they were he
gets became obsessed with his [ __ ]
legal case
um
who the [ __ ] am i to say lenny bruce
wasn't funny i'm sorry
i'm out of sorts today
jesus christ i mean it's because of that
guy i can [ __ ] sit here and do
everything that i do
at a way much
lower level
saint [ __ ] every other word my apologies
all right
to his estate
anybody else who's still alive however
the [ __ ] that works
um
all right that's it i'm done i'm done
bitching
i bitched a lot
all right i pitched about the lakers i
bitched about people on bicycles
jesus bill well you really went after
the [ __ ]
the sacred [ __ ]
really looking back on this podcast to
what i've done here i don't know if i'm
proud of it but it felt good to get it
out all right so that's it have a great
weekend you [ __ ] enjoy the music and
there'll be a bonus episode of me
bitching about something from a couple
years ago it's probably the nba all
right i'll see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday august 5th
how are you how you doing this morning
oh that's just fantastic
this is going to be another subdued
william burr here on the monday morning
podcast as you can tell i wasn't able to
find a [ __ ] cord
for my mixer so um
the lovely nia is gonna send me mine
uh so next this will be the last week of
this kind of stuff so i've had
difficulty trying to find
basically everything here
in new orleans for those of you just
listening you haven't listened for the
past couple weeks i'm here in new
orleans
i'm doing the uh
what do you call it the final episode of
glee for this season it's like some
three hour extravaganza so i have to be
out here forever and you know
like i mentioned i am going to be
shirtless in the cafeteria scene so i've
been trying to uh trying to get healthy
food out here
which is practically impossible
i haven't been able to find it if
there's any new orleans people i guess
they don't say nolan's by the way
i was told that the other night that
they don't say that that's just some
hollywood [ __ ]
and then uh i taught that person how to
properly save boston
baw boston not boston
so we both had a laugh and then we ate
some fried [ __ ] oysters because
everything's fried down here
you know i go into verizon i need a new
cell phone charger
you know they didn't have the entire
thing they just had the part you plug
into your [ __ ] computer so unless i
was gonna walk around my computer
and then bring that plug
and plug that in and then plug the
[ __ ] cell phone into my computer that
was the only way for me to charge it
when i was on the road
so i'm sitting there going like you know
i'm becoming a tub of [ __ ] here and i
have my big shirtless scene
you know
i'm singing uh
8675 309 jenny
uh but they jazz it up a little bit but
uh
anyway so i find some place to get a
juice
and uh even then the way they do the
juice you know usually you use the apple
you use the fruit to give it a little
zing so you can drink the [ __ ] green
[ __ ]
but they do it the opposite down here
it's apple juice and then they'll add
like half a leaf of kale in there
and i just kind of hopping yourself up
on sugar
so um i actually i do have a game plan
though people
um after your wonderful suggestions
were you like bill why don't you watch
that documentary fat
sick and nearly dead
and i'm like well yeah i've already
watched those you know food inc and i
watched uh
uh
try lock gertouz [ __ ] uh morgan
spurlock try like gertu
yeah it's a famous percussionist from
india
um
i [ __ ] uh i mean
that's how you even say his name bill
just get to the point all right
um the [ __ ] was my point
oh morgan spurlock is that his name i
watched that what he ate mcdonald's for
30 [ __ ] days in a row and uh i mean
you know what's great about that you
knew what you knew his body was gonna be
junk but
secretly haven't you always wanted to do
that
just say [ __ ] it and just blow your body
out
you know
just deep i don't know how much weight
you actually could gain if you really
put your mind to it
you know
this is what i do i would start with a
grand slam breakfast
and then i have to take a nap because
i'm old when you get older by the way
when you eat really bad you know rather
than just running outside like you do as
a youngster it takes a toll on you you
actually have to go lay down
and try to sleep yourself
back into some sort of balance i don't
know what but uh yeah i'd probably start
with that
lunch time what would i do steak and
cheese
see you know what it is that kind of
food so [ __ ] me up now i can't even
enjoy it anymore
that's what happens as you get older
it's like your [ __ ] guts
are like some engine that your entire
life you were down like two quarts of
oil on and it just doesn't run as well
as it used to you know back when you
were younger you could do [ __ ]
neutral drops and [ __ ]
be driving 40 miles an hour and just
yank the emergency brake you cut the
wheel and almost tip over your [ __ ]
volkswagen fox
like my buddy did back in the day you
can't do that anymore as you get older
you know so if you are older and every
time you eat you then have to
immediately fall asleep
uh you're down a few quarts
[Laughter]
it's time for it you might want to put a
synthetic in there so anyway so um
i've been uh you know days i'm not
working
i've been kind of bored i know a lot of
you guys already know what i'm working
on here and a lot of you guys always go
bill why do you try to keep it such a
big [ __ ] secret what you're doing you
can just go to your imdb page and figure
out what you're doing well do you ever
think that that maybe that that's the
[ __ ] method to my madness see if i
just told you [ __ ] what what i'm doing
down here in new orleans
you'd be a humble brag or you'd give me
[ __ ]
you know easy there kid don't forget
where you came from all right
um
so what i do is i deliberately act vague
and then you know people send me then
they just go to imdb and they end up
knowing more about what the [ __ ] i'm
doing
than if i told you anyways and then
people send me emails like bill i don't
understand why you're being so vague
it's so easy to find out what you're
doing you're doing this project with
blah blah blah blah it's like there you
go you dumb [ __ ]
it's exactly what i wanted i wanted you
to have the information i tricked you
okay you're coming at me like you just
solved the murder case like you're
[ __ ] columbo and you're looking away
with your crazy eye rubbing your
forehead and i'm standing there
flabbergasted hearing a heartbeat under
the floorboards you got it ass backwards
that's why i'm vague
i want to give you something to do at
work what else you're going to do sit
there and stare at your spreadsheets
figure out how much [ __ ] grapes cost
in the next 20 minutes
screaming buy sell i've actually been
doing really well
with my weight here oh so anyway so uh i
finally give in
and uh i'm like all right i'm not
working today i'm gonna go uh
i'm gonna go uh
you know i'm gonna watch this [ __ ]
fat sick and nearly dead and i gotta
tell you man
it was awesome
i absolutely loved it
and uh
i felt bad for trash and fat people on
my podcast
my my uh
billy shade billy shane to get back and
get back into shape you know where i
just make fun of the fatties
um i mean it was always done in jess but
i don't know there's one guy that he
runs into that uh
i don't know i felt bad for the dude but
anyways he goes on this juice fest
so of course now i'm like obsessed with
it
you know just so i can get some of this
these fried clams and
all this stuff these po boys sandwiches
just try to get these out of my system
because i'm sick of having to take a nap
every time i eat out here
so i think i'm going to buy a mini
juicer
and a bunch of kale and that type of
[ __ ] and uh
juice it up and then just shove it down
my [ __ ] pile
you know and believe it or not it fills
you up
fills you up you get used to it then you
start craving that
and uh and then the best part is you
don't have to go to the gym
that's what it's really all about people
that's the number one reason
to eat well
it's not so you live longer so you don't
have to go to the gym
you don't have to go to the gym and you
give clothes still fit right
you know
i don't know you was funny somebody the
other day actually sent me an email
going bill do you have any idea how many
times you say you know
during a podcast and it was
it's just like yes
of course i do
you know
how the [ __ ] wouldn't i know that i
think i don't listen back to these
things as i upload them to try to see if
they're funny or not you know i gotta
admit if i don't think they're funny i
shut them off really quickly but they
start going
i like them
but i do notice that i say it that that
that much but maybe can i have a
catchphrase
you know
that was actually not even uh
i didn't wasn't even on purpose you know
i'm in my own [ __ ] head
i don't want to do that
anyways i'm still here at the hotel i'm
gonna buy a juicer
and uh
i just figured two two out of three
meals a day
i'm gonna drink that [ __ ]
and uh
you know when i come home i won't have
an even bigger head
i guess that's the way you kind of you
uh
if you come back off the road
and your head isn't three sizes bigger
does your girlfriend think you cheated
on her
like what are you in such good shape for
but if you come back it's like a fat
booze i'm just okay he was faithful
i don't know
anyways let's talk about let's talk
about major league baseball something
that i have not watched
since 2010
when i just got sick of everybody you
know testing positive for stuff
particularly people on my team
and i was just like yeah you know it
just kind of took all the uh the glory
out of those championships and stuff
that the red sox won it did not take any
glory away from beating the yankees in
2004 though did not at all because you
know they had just as many guys if not
some of the worst defenders
you know i think andy pettit would have
got more [ __ ] if he wasn't into jesus
any any major league baseball players
listening to if you're listening to this
and you're doing if you're on the juice
there
what i would do and you feel like the
hounds are nipping at your heels i would
air quote find jesus you know they just
start [ __ ] writing on your glove
when you wave to the when you wave to
the camera
jesus is love jesus saves
jesus is my homie
yeah you know whatever whatever the [ __ ]
else you say
so then when you uh
you [ __ ] up then you can just do like
that stuff like those televangelists we
just sit there crying i have sinned
against you
and people seem to forgive you
so let's get to alex rodriguez everybody
oh by the way if you'd like to know
who's in first place in major league
baseball i actually looked it up i had
no idea i mean i knew the red sox were
doing well
um
the red sox
the tigers
and the oakland age
are in first place in the american
league and then
see if i can remember this the national
league
it's the uh is it the braves
the dodgers dodgers are actually doing
well making me eat crow
you know because i laughed at them last
year when they were like we were like
hey we have a hundred million dollars
worth of [ __ ] players who aren't
doing [ __ ] for us and the dodgers are
like well [ __ ] we'll take them
you know like they're playing a
different game over there i don't know
why you would do that but thank you for
doing it
and you know what thanks to you it works
for all of us
the red sox and dodgers are both in
first place and my squad if i had been
paying attention
the pittsburgh pirates
you know i found out the pirates are in
first place
i was sitting in a bar uh eating fried
corn flakes whatever the [ __ ] they have
down here
and um
they had on a game oh well the pirates
are on pirates and cardinals i really
love the national league from way back
in the day
i used to like it because so many of the
teams played on astroturf and
when i was a little kid i thought that
that was way cooler than playing on
grass
like now grass is way cooler than
astroturf astroturf looks cheesy but in
the late 70s
um early 80s astroturf was the [ __ ]
you know the whole inf field was
astroturf except around the bags
and uh it just seemed like a faster game
they were playing hit and run
guy gets on first you bumped him over to
second stealing bases and over in the
american league it was all about you
know people just standing there trying
to smash the ball over the fence
and uh back then home run hitters would
would hit like [ __ ] 278 if you hit
280 that was considered like a you know
you were a solid guy
um
i don't know maybe you are now but like
they just didn't put up the numbers the
way they they did during the roid era
actually
obviously i should say so anyways i'm
sitting there and i and i'm like oh
pirate pirates and cardinals this is
like the old days
you know
and uh
i'm looking in the crowd and it seems
like everybody's wearing pirate [ __ ]
and i'm just like and the place looks
like it's sold out and i'm like wait a
minute the pirates are selling out a
game
and i'm like this must be a cardinals
home game
and look at their jerseys what was weird
was their their way jersey said
cardinals so then that made me feel like
it was a home game because i thought
unless i saw it
the wrong way or
i misremembered it as politicians say
but i was under the impression
that uh away
baseball teams when you're home you have
the name of your team like the red sox
then you go on the way it says boston
you know you're at home it says the
indians you go on the road it says
cleveland so i guess you know people who
don't know [ __ ] about baseball know what
city you're from i have no idea
uh but anyways it turned out that it was
a pirates home game and it looked like
it was sold out
so uh
i don't know that makes me excited but
haven't they they've been doing that the
last couple of years
you know my fandom of the pirates is
from [ __ ] you know
just watching baseball in the late 70s
and that we are family team was like one
of my favorites
and uh i rooted against the orioles
because the orioles kicked the red sox
ass
in 79 with their unbelievable pitching
staff
um
i would always root for the national
league teams
i guess because it was actually it was
really exciting to see them play
because they didn't have uh
there was no mlb packages like if you
lived in boston all you got was the red
sox game and then they would have the uh
the game of the week
and uh
if you missed that then you watch mel
allen's this week in baseball which was
the [ __ ]
used to come on saturday afternoons
[Music]
and then
you'd come on whatever the [ __ ] he would
say
that was the that was supposed to be the
exciting theme song that started the
show
and then they ended the show with
something a little uh not up tempo to
just let you know it was a beautiful
game and they would just show it in slow
motion and the song
[Music]
[ __ ] people just doing all this
amazing [ __ ] in like slow motion you
know what's amazing about that song is
there's probably a 40 person orchestra
all right there was no auto tune there
was no drum machine there was no [ __ ]
one guy on a giant keyboard that could
make all those songs it was like 40
people getting paid
all working together
pointing at each other afterwards and
going out and having a couple of schlitz
so anyways
um
[ __ ] am i talking about here yeah so i
started watching baseball
again i haven't started watching
baseball who's kidding who but um
i was psyched to see that the pirates
are in uh first place and i'm actually
happy for the dodgers believe it or not
i have a tough time with the dodgers
because i was a huge fan of them when i
was a kid
because of the 77 and 78 world series
when they played the uh the new york
yankees because i hated the yankees and
we could never beat them back then
um so i would root for the for the
dodgers and i remember feeling bad for
tommy john
because uh
he lost
in 77-78
with the uh dodgers and then in 81 he
went to the yankees which was
unforgivable to me and then the yankees
played the dodgers again in the world
series and then the dodgers finally won
the guy went oh for [ __ ] three
poor bastard and he had an operation
named after
um
him and lou gehrig
no one was in operation was a disease
hey bill why don't you shut the [ __ ] up
all right i will let let me read a
little bit of advertising here and then
we'll get back when i come back i'm
going to tease you a little here people
i'm going to talk about that whole a-rod
situation
um
here we go all right dollar shave club
everybody been talking about this for
the last couple of weeks and i got to
tell you a long time ago i used to do a
bit about this in my act about why do
they act like those disposable razors
are some sort of gold bullion why are
they locked behind the the
that plastic glass
why do they act like it's it's this
amazing thing it's a little hunk of crap
that shouldn't cost more than a buck
right
so here we go
i did that bit like 78 years ago
see what i did was i just did a joke
about it these geniuses actually did
something about it started a a company
here and they're probably making a
zillion dollars and you know what i say
i say good for them
i say good for them dollar shave club
everybody
um
it's a cool brand and they send you
these quality razors right to your door
every month you don't have to think
about it you don't have to wait in line
get someone to unlock them from a cage
and pay way too much money for a bunch
of features that don't even fit your old
handle shaving has become such a mess
but not with dollar shave club all right
saves me time it saves me money and the
razors are fantastic and i can i can
guarantee you that they've been sending
those things right to my house i don't
have to deal with it anymore i have an
awful cvs right down the street where
there's always like a 20 minute line
because they only have open you know one
register
um give it a shot you know
i want you to try it go to dollar shave
club forward slash burr support this
show go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bur or click the dollar
shave club banner on the podcast page
billboard.com that's dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr you don't have to
think about it anymore once a month they
send you a bunch of new blades you have
a new blade
every damn week okay
and then the ladies are giving you more
kiss on the cheek there
evoice
everybody you're screening calls closing
deals and making money
all while lounging poolside in the
summer sun thanks to who e-voice e-voice
is a better way to connect with the
people that drive your business e-voice
will forward business calls to your home
mobile or any number you choose wherever
you are e-voice will find you don't have
time to take a call no worries it's
routed to your voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as a text
message message sorry e-voice not only
gives you an edge over your competitors
it takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now with e-voice you
can create the appearance of a whole
office building of departments when
customers call you a sales department
customer support tech support you name
it it sounds like you got it and it
works with any phone even yourself
hey it's summer don't be stuck at the
office all day you jackass free yourself
for a free 30-day trial of eboyz so you
can see what i'm talking about over here
go to evoice.com and enter enter the
promo code bill for your 30-day free
trial that's evoice dot com promo code
bill or go to the podcast page on
billbird.com and click on the evoice
banner
all right that was painless i only had
one screw up there you like that people
i think i finally got my game together
with reading these uh
these advertisements
you know
you know what i am i'm like a number one
draft pick bust when it comes to that
[ __ ]
not quite a bust but i'm about five six
years in the original team i was on uh
dropped me down to number three on the
depth chat and now i got traded and i'm
playing back up over in [ __ ]
minnesota but the first two went down
and now i'm getting in
all right this is now skip bayless is
yelling about me
saying that he doesn't think that i can
actually read these [ __ ] things
without screwing it up while stephen a
smith goes blasphemy blasphemy
um all right a-rod everybody
here's my thing about this son of a
[ __ ]
this guy
gets a lifetime ban
and that somehow voids his contract
the yankees are somehow able to get out
of that contract i swear to [ __ ] god
you might as well just have the the
commissioner of baseball might as well
just be steinbrenner's son
okay
how much
[ __ ] can the yankees [ __ ] get away
with do you remember the red sox wanted
to get a run we had the deal in place
if baseball came in and was like no
we had the deal was done and baseball
came in and said no that's bad for
baseball it's bad for baseball to have
on yet another big time free agent go to
the red sox because that's when we were
becoming the yankees right
and then
a-rod goes to the yankees
somehow that wasn't bad for baseball to
have two of the three best short stops
in the league at the time on the same
team one of them never to play shortstop
again to have to learn a new position at
third base if you remember this is
pre-steroids and all that so some of
these names don't hold the weight they
they did back in the day but their
infield
was giambi jeter and a-rod
and then there was talks that maybe they
were going to sign nomar to play second
place second base i remember jambi be
like dude he was like dude that would be
awesome
i i just might be thinking like how
would that be awesome
where is the [ __ ] in front of them so
anyways
we try to get a rod it's bad for
baseball the yankees do it
and they already had like [ __ ] every
goddamn free agent in the league
at every position other than their four
[ __ ] five core guys from their own uh
uh farm team
and somehow that was okay
all right
and that was just a an ongoing story in
baseball was the red sox just never
just we couldn't win no matter what we
did it blew up in our face and even when
we made moves and got a big guy it was
considered bad for baseball you go back
to the 70s we had raleigh fingers
signed him bad for baseball
you know yank that out reggie jackson
can can we can the [ __ ] yankees sign
him apps are [ __ ] lukely
i don't know what i don't know what what
our pens look like but for some reason
they were bad for baseball so anyways
for once
after 86 years of flailing you know the
deal somehow it worked in our favor so i
have thoroughly enjoyed
watching a-rod
flame out
and in watching the yankees trying to
get out of that contract and just not
being able
to get this 200 million
albatross
off from around their neck i i've
thoroughly [ __ ] enjoyed it
they tried to humiliate him they they
benched him during crucial moments in
like the playoffs and a-rod doesn't give
a [ __ ] he just sits there like a [ __ ]
robot going well you know whatever's
good for the team i don't give a [ __ ]
you know just just keep paying me i
don't give a [ __ ] and i've completely
enjoyed it
and they still have another five years
of this nightmare
five years like 114 million dollars they
got to give this this
matinee idol looking
bust
and i have completely enjoyed every
second of it
and
um
in my world it's like i got another five
years to just sort of you know not like
i watch a ton of baseball anymore which
is kind of sad
uh
i gotta get back into it everybody but i
can i can't get back into it at the the
the upper levels i just can't i can't
watch these [ __ ] you know
juggernaut teams i i gotta i gotta i
gotta be watching kansas city
you know the padres the pirates even the
pirates in first place but i don't think
they have any major league signings in
major free agent signings but anyways
so i thought i had another five years of
this show to watch
and now all of a sudden i'm worried that
it's going to get cancelled i'll tell
you right now
if
because of this suspension the yankees
are somehow able to get out of this
contract
and save themselves 114 million dollars
which to them is just a drop in the
bucket
the way they ass rape their fans every
home game
the way they take every one of those
poor yankee fans with their pinstripe
shirts and their classic yankee hats and
they just bend them over the hot dog
stand
and just stick that pinstripe dick right
up their ass no lube
you know i really feel bad for the total
[ __ ]
ass raping that every
every yankee fan takes when you go to
the ballpark
i mean if i was a yankee fan
i would not go to that new [ __ ]
um
beautiful baseball stadium slash growing
up gaudy house
such a weird stadium
if you haven't been to it you should
definitely go
uh but i i suggest eating a thanksgiving
dinner before you go there or you know
one of your kids will not be going to
college
um
but you go to that stadium it's such a
weird stadium where like there's
literally some breathtaking
views as you walk around that park and
every time you're like oh my god this is
amazing they really did it right then
they'll just have you know some jackass
like
just some some [ __ ] look how much
money we got
just
you know what it is
it's kind of like
this blend of um
i don't know like what's a great
ballpark that they built that that's new
but it's all i guess maybe the jake when
it first came out
it's kind of the the perfect it's a
blend of of uh
the beautiful new ones
that conjure up the old [ __ ] and like
dallas cowboys stadium
where if you've never been to that you
got to go to that one just once just to
see that absolutely [ __ ] that eyesore
of a television that they have hanging
up there it's the dumbest thing i've
ever seen in my life i swear to god when
i go to that stadium i always think if
bobby kelly
designed a football stadium this is
exactly what it looked like
dude look how big the tv is dude
i don't have to go anywhere dude i just
sit here and watch it
um
dallas cowboys stadium is an absolute
[ __ ] abomination
and uh
and it's just because of that tv
everything else is actually
it's beautiful
if you could just get that [ __ ] tv
that tv it's like a drunk at a holiday
family gathering you know what i mean no
matter how good the food is not how
great it is to see everybody
all conversation everything is drowned
out by the [ __ ] the guy over there
you know your uncle
who keeps dabbling in the oxy he's
telling you that he's clean but he isn't
you know that's what that [ __ ] tv's
like
so anyways
the hell am i saying here
as a fan
of sports
and my hatred of the new york yankees
i'm
really hoping
that the yankees feel like oh maybe we
can get out of it maybe we can get out
of it and then they they still can't
knowing full well that in the long run
it's not going to mean [ __ ] to them 100
some million dollars doesn't mean [ __ ]
to them it's just annoying
and that's basically all i can really
hope for at this point so um
maybe i'll write some letters
i'll write some letters to uh the
commissioner of baseball tell them that
i'm dying or something and that my
bucket
my bucket list or something something
has to do with a rut
i just really want that that
i just want to be able to talk to him
sometime while he's on the field that's
that's my make-a-wish thing i want to
look into those zombie robotic eyes
uh
i like how he's actually pissed now and
says that he's being singled out it's
like well you kind of made yourself a
target with the steroids for the second
time you [ __ ] jerk off
he really is like uh
he has an inability to to step outside
himself and see how he's coming off
an absolute jackass and i can't think of
a
better person
to be to be wearing the pinstripes and
represent what that organization is all
about
they're clean-shaven
steroid abusers
unlike the red sox
who uh
i don't know what we look like we look
like we're going to an almond brothers
concert
uh
i'm just trying to get yankee fans going
they use jerry royce too
all right let's let's plow ahead here
everybody um
they held it out she's going to talk
about something there the hell was i
going to bring up there
oh let's move on to this let's just keep
the uh
the sport thing going here
oh no no no i remember what it is i oh i
owe an apology this wasn't my fault but
i have to apologize on behalf of the
theater that el paso show got uh
rescheduled
as i mentioned because of the active
work i got down here in new orleans i
was only able to do the first two dates
of the red state tour
um none of the shows are canceled
they've all been rescheduled i know it's
a pain in the ass i know people make
plans i apologize
um i announced it here on on um
on the podcast i
you know
i don't know what the [ __ ] else i could
have done to let people know go to el i
guess
the theater out there in el paso i don't
know what happened but some people
didn't get the word that the show was
canceled and i guess uh there was some
people that showed up so uh i apologize
i hope you're listening to this i will
try to tweet about it and maybe you'll
be able to get i don't know if you
follow me on twitter or not
but to let you know
the uh
the new date of the el paso date is
september 13th
right i'm sorry september 12th
september 12th is the new date
and uh
i apologize to anybody who showed up i
can't believe what a pain in the ass
that is i hope nobody drove
you know ah jesus someone's gonna be
like dude i drove four [ __ ] hours or
i had a plane ticket or something like
that so i feel horrible about it
so because of that i'm just gonna
announce my dates
right here right now i'm just going to
read through
a bunch of these as quickly as i can
so uh there's no more confusion
all right and then somehow there still
will be confusion and then somehow
someone's going to get mad at me and
i'll get a [ __ ] angry email or
whatever apologize for the clicking here
people
see if i can bring this up with this
horrific
internet here come on you can do it you
can do it all right here we go
these are the shows i have coming up
and i'm even going to read the ones that
don't even have ticket links
all right
all right this is the deal
august 23rd i'm at the mgm grand
connecticut
august 24th university of cincinnati
august 27th cobb's comedy club with
brian regan
all proceeds are going to charity we're
doing a co-headliner that one's actually
already sold out all right red state
tour rescheduled dates for those of you
in colorado september 4th september 6th
boulder colorado pikes peak
all right tickets are all on sale for
these
uh september 7th i'm in coachella
california at the spotlight 29 casino
once again rescheduled uh red state
tours september 12th
el paso texas and because of that
rescheduled i'm also now doing uh
san antonio texas first time i've never
been there at the lilla cockrell theater
september 13th
and i know what you're thinking bill
you're doing a show on september 14th no
i am not
but i'm not leaving texas
and what does saturday
in september in texas
mean to anybody in texas huh
college football [ __ ] i'm going
to texas a m alabama
and i am rooting for the aggies and i
will be drunk and i will still be
screaming alabama the dream ends tonight
so look for me out in the parking lot
with my sunburned giant head
and i'll see you in the stadium
all right continuing on
september 19th i'm in west virginia
west virginia university morgantown west
virginia
uh then i got pittsburgh on september
20th
all these all these shows are on sale
people up in canada toronto ontario
september 21st the queen elizabeth
theater
september 28th not one but two shows at
the famous chicago theater first one is
sold out i believe
uh second show 10 30
has been added
uh now here's some that aren't on sale
but are coming up october third fourth
fifth
seventh
and eighth
no no i'm sorry
let's write that october third fourth
and fifth
i'll be in san jose
seattle washington and phoenix arizona
those tickets are not on sale yet but
i'm just letting you know where i'm
gonna be and i'll announce them as soon
as they're available
on twitter so follow me on twitter if
you're not on twitter or facebook or
whatever
um november 7th this is not on sale and
over november 8th this is
and 9th 7th 8th and 9th sorry these are
not on sale yet either
i'll be in washington dc new york city
in upper darby pennsylvania that'll be
constitution hall the beacon theater and
tower theater
all right november 15th rescheduled red
state tour
deadwood south dakota
november 16th rescheduled
red state tour brady theater in tulsa
oklahoma
and another red state the orpheum
theater wichita kansas
november 17th all right and that will
conclude the red state tour i apologize
for having to reschedule but uh
i'm still coming i could have been a
[ __ ] and just canceled
you know sat out here in [ __ ] new
orleans with my shirt off getting ready
for my big number
um
what else southern connecticut state
university on the 23rd
all right now here's the big european
tour
people from europe were asking me about
this [ __ ] i apologize for this being
really long but i have to get this
information out here because i do not
want people showing up
when i'm not going to be somewhere all
right december 5th i'm in amsterdam
tickets are on sale december 7th
i'm in london
show sold out they added another show um
december 9th
i'm in dublin at the vicar theater
december 10th i'm at the savvy theater
in helsinki finland december 11th
i'm at the uh copenhagen i'm in the
bremen theater in copenhagen denmark
december 12th i'm in oslo norway
december 13th i'm in stockholm sweden
now here's two shows that people don't
know about december 15th
i'm gonna be at at harper
silverberg hall
in
reykjavik
iceland hope i'm saying that right never
been to iceland i'm really excited and
the biggest teaser of them all you know
i don't work new years
because i go to the rose bowl every year
well i finally decided this year well i
live in los angeles why don't i do a big
show in los angeles and why don't i put
my buddies
the rose bowl legends
uh
[ __ ] joe batnick
and jason lawhead were all do a show
the night before new year's eve if you
don't have new year's eve plans and you
live in los angeles we're going to be at
the wilton theater
right down there on uh wilshire wilshere
and western
so tickets are not on sale for that one
yet so there you go now you know as much
as i do about my schedule and once again
sincerest apologies to anybody
any of the four bastards that showed up
for my show
in el paso that was not to be
i don't know how that happened
um
so there you go all right back to the
back to the uh
the podcast here everybody so as
mentioned i'm down here in new orleans
i've been making fun of the food but uh
i've been having the best time in new
orleans as they say if you can't have a
good time down here there's something
wrong with you
and uh
i went out the other night i guess they
shoot a lot of movies down here because
it's really cheap
he gave him a great deal or whatever and
i had a buddy of mine who was shooting
something else and he had just wrapped
and he called me out we went off
met up at this hotel
and uh
just you know what i'll actually i
usually don't name a name this will hype
his movie was craig robinson who's doing
uh they just wrapped on uh hot tub time
machine part two and uh
craig is one just one of those guys
who's just
i don't know unbelievably charismatic
like i watched i was watching that guy
that guy was having more goddamn fun in
one night than i think i've ever had in
my life
you know
just he he's
there was a live band playing he went up
he played piano
you know singing and making everybody
laugh and then he [ __ ] called me up
to go do some stand-up i of course was
defensive turned the crowd off and then
i got off stage
but later on that night when the bandit
left
um he went back up started playing piano
and i went up there played some drums
full i swear to god like 45 minutes
or like an hour
and uh
it's the most fun i think i've had in a
long long time and i was stoned sober
didn't have a drop of alcohol you know
whenever i have an acting gig i try to
lay off the boost so my [ __ ] giant
head doesn't seem even bigger no one
wants to see that on the screen so um
i've been doing that walking around
checking out the city avoiding
what do you call it uh bourbon street
you know i just i i sound like the date
rapey sort of vibe on that street so uh
there is a laundromat that is on that so
it's kind of funny i've been doing my
laundry down that way
and just walking
on that street
like in broad daylight after you know
show your dance or whatever the [ __ ]
happened the night before
it's just uh
you ever walk by a strip club during the
day it's just really just
it's just not a good look
it's just
i don't know what about it is at night
time when you see those purple neon
light bulbs and you have in the bag or
something it actually looks like
something appealing but when you just
see it
in broad daylight it's [ __ ] brutal so
anyways uh
i've actually been getting into like you
know they've been talking about lsu
football down here and the saints like
every single day they're getting so
[ __ ] amped up for football
um
i'm actually caught up in this
excitement down here and uh
i saw that the saints have a preseason
game friday night
and if you think i'm not going
well if i have to work that night
obviously i'm not going but if i don't
have to there's no [ __ ] way i'm not
going because the superdome now that
they redid it it was already iconic it's
you owe it to yourself to come down here
and go to a game it's it's uh
it's beautiful which brings me to their
basketball team i don't know if you guys
know this but the uh
new orleans hornets are no more
than now called the uh
new orleans pelicans
just gonna pause and let you take that
in for a second it's called they're
called the pelicans
which is arguably the worst [ __ ] name
of any goddamn sports team
i i'm gonna motion i'm gonna make uh
a suggestion here
any new team
at this point do not name your team
after an animal
because evidently there's no good ones
left
there's 122 [ __ ] teams and i think
just all the good
ferocious ones
are taken unless you just want to go
obscure
and just start picking like
names of like poisonous snakes and
[ __ ] up animals from different
countries
which i don't know why would you why
would you do that you know
the new orleans taipans you know you
wouldn't do that [ __ ] the pelicans
so i looked up their logo and i'm like
if they made like a basketball net out
of that bird's [ __ ] double chin
uh
i don't know what i was gonna do but i
looked it up but you know what they did
conveniently is they they got rid of its
double chin like it had like a facelift
so what i think they should do now if
they're gonna go like that if they're
gonna so horribly misrepresent that bird
not have its giant [ __ ] double chin
and somehow have this streamlined chin
you know
uh i i think they should just they
should just put those [ __ ]
you know those lips those plastic
surgery lips that you got [ __ ] i i am am
i even being remotely [ __ ] funny on
this goddamn podcast
such a [ __ ] handicap i can't hear
myself right now i don't have my
microphone it's like my kryptonite
whatever make the [ __ ] thing look
like a kardashian kardashian's mom
i'm actually you know what it's such a
[ __ ]
you know what i don't like about it
they they try to make it look cool
it's like if you're gonna be the
pelicans just embrace it and what you
have to have is do do the cartoony
version
of the pelican right where it's got a
cigar in its mouth and it's giving you
the thumbs up with its [ __ ] wing
you know it's got a [ __ ] beer in one
hand or something in cigars you should
just get a hawaiian shirt if you're
going to be the pelicans you got to do
that stop trying to make that bird look
cool
it's not cool
is this iron been [ __ ] rocking like
that the entire time it's not [ __ ]
cool
there's two logos that really [ __ ] up
the new orleans pelicans and then uh
the [ __ ] miami dolphins who never
should have changed
they shouldn't have changed their logo
it had been it was always a kind of a
douchey logo
but had been around long enough and
they've done so many legendary things
that you kind of like you respected it
i mean when i saw that logo i thought
about don shula i thought about larry
zonka jim kick bob greasy
that whole era
gario your premium what the [ __ ] his
name is
and um
gary a premium that's why people used to
go bald you know like [ __ ] lou grant
was the dump of these chemicals on your
head and having that wisp
of grass on top of your head uh
or i thought about dan marino
ma dupa mark clayton all of that [ __ ]
that's what i thought about
and uh for some [ __ ] reason they
decided to change it which i think is a
desperate move at this point
they're trying to make more money
because now everybody has to go out and
buy the new logo is never better
look at the new england patriots i think
we have like the ugliest [ __ ]
uniforms in the league that awful silver
with that you know whatever they call
the flying elvis on the side
i hate it i i've never bought
wow i just realized that
i've never bought anything with that
logo on it never bought a jersey or
anything i've hated it from way back
when drew bledsoe first came and it was
it was more sky blue as opposed to the
darker blue
with that silver i always just thought
it was horrifically [ __ ] ugly
um
but the dolphins new logo you know what
their logo basically looks like
do you know like when a corporation
accidentally spills like nuclear waste
into the water supply so then they
change their name and they try to come
up with like a
like a logo that makes it seem like they
give a [ __ ] about the environment like
bp did
you know bp went from this
logo that looked like they they drilled
oil out of the [ __ ] ground like what
they did
and then sprayed it on baby birds and
[ __ ] sweatshop children
now they got that one it's all green and
yellow like you don't know if they plant
corn or it just looks like grass and
sunshine that's what i feel like the new
dolphins have done
is that what you feel like bill bill
considering you're not that funny this
week why don't you just read some of the
letters
instead of continuing to just flail as
you're riffing
um
all right i'll get on to it
all right here's the first one facial
scare
bill a few notes
oh you know what i'm just [ __ ] up
this week i got to read these last two
uh advertisements i can't read them too
late to the podcast because for some
reason i think you think you guys just
shut these things off
uh all right hulu plus everybody i'm
sure you've tried hulu.com if you
haven't you should
but uh but if you've already tried
hulu.com i want to tell you about hulu
plus
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere stream it on
your tv or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet why stand in line
or ride a train and just stare at your
feet you could be watching your favorite
shows on hulu plus hula plus is a great
way to binge watch your favorite shows
i'm gonna use hulu plus to catch up on
all the old family guy episodes i missed
when i was on the road i guess i'm
always supposed to put in the show that
i really want to watch
um
person of interest
i think i'll do that um didn't see my
episode of new girl that's on hulu plus
two and if i ever decide to watch lost
which i won't hulu plus is the place for
all that hulu plus is only 7.99 a month
that's 7.99 for all the shows and movies
you can watch catch up on current shows
binge on your old favorite or catch a
great movie you can do it all on hulu
plus everybody right now you can try
hulu plus for a couple of weeks free on
me when you go to the podcast page
billboard.com and click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com
please make sure you use the hulu
plus dot com slash bill so you get an
extended free trial
and so that you know also so that they
know we sent you it helps us to keep the
lights on and gives you a better deal
one more time for the extended free
trial hulu plus dot com slash bill
all right i'm reading very well this
week everybody i'm gonna pat myself on
the back
um and put a little pressure here i bet
i can go through this whole one without
screwing up once
all right here we go legal zoom
most americans don't have a will but why
you don't want government rules
dictating what happens to your property
and minor children so why procrastinate
most people say it's too expensive or
too time consuming my answer to that is
legalzoom.com too expensive you're gonna
love legal zooms reasonable prices too
time-consuming most people finish the
online process in just 20 minutes and
we're not talking some fill-in-the-blank
form your will is state-specific and
personalized based on your information
best of all legalzoom has 12 years of
experience helping people with important
legal matters it's national make a will
month everybody even though we're in
august
so don't wait any longer go to
legalzoom.com today and get 15 off your
last will
ah damn it i was gonna do it get 15 off
your yeah it is off your last will
oh last will and testament is that short
for that i don't know but this offer
ends soon or get a living trust and you
receive a poor over will absolutely free
to get you your special discount be sure
to enter burr in the referral box at
checkout for wills powers of attorney
trust and more go to legalzoom.com
legalzoom can provide self-help services
at your specific direction or connect
you with an attorney
but they're not a law firm there you go
god damn it i went 14 and two in the
regular season and i just blew the first
playoff game that's what i just did
there
i pulled the peyton manning
um
all right where the hell am i here
all right facial scare
what the [ __ ] is it
all right bill this past weekend i went
to vegas to visit my brother and his
buddy who currently reside there they
actually caught your most recent show in
vegas and had a phenomenal time oh
that's awesome thank you
said i left last thursday from tampa and
i soon i touched down in vegas i
received an out of nowhere text from the
girl that got away i was shook this
broad used to live in tampa about two
and a half years ago but she moved out
to la to pursue her career as an actress
the two of us attended the university of
tampa a few years ago and had an
on-again off-again relationship long
story short i was in a relationship with
another girl we went on break and i met
this girl and was
hooked so anyways her text said hey who
are you going to vegas with because i'm
going to be there this weekend too
my guess is that she had seen my social
media she had been
my guess is that she had seen on my
social media that i was going to be in
vegas when i read the text i was very
surprised and pretty pumped because we
hadn't talked in a long time and like i
said she was the one that got away she's
absolutely gorgeous and she also happens
to be a really good person as well
jesus christ people what could go wrong
here
we hooked up in vegas and it was amazing
to see her we all went out did our thing
and had one of the best weekends i've
had in my life i'd give you more details
but you know what happens in vegas stays
in vegas all right you gave her the old
meat hammer way to be subtle
anyways
the reason why i'm writing to you
though is because on the plane
right back to tampa i was thinking about
mine and this girl's relationship and
all of our history and a pretty comical
slash genius story came to mind about
her
i know this is getting long but i hope
it's not as long and boring as that guy
running to explain the [ __ ] origins
of jimmy's a couple of weeks ago jesus
christ uh but anyways like i said when i
first met her i was immediately
attracted to her natural beauty beauty
and her personality she was one of these
ladies who didn't have to wear makeup or
do anything special to look sexy however
one of the first weekends we spent
together
i wake up and with her in bed one
morning i go to give her a kiss
and i am i am immediately troubled
the way the morning sun was shining into
the window on her face exposed something
i wasn't ready for
that early in the morning this broad has
dark hair and for the first time i
noticed she had some dark hair above her
lip
i was really surprised i didn't catch it
before but it wasn't a thick mustache or
anything it was just like the peach fuzz
a 12 year old boy has before he starts
shaving regularly regardless i was
taking i was taken back
and from that morning and from that
point on that morning it was all i could
notice
ah jesus
isn't it crazy how visual guys are
that's it
take the most beautiful woman in the
world you put it give her a mustache we
can't that's all we can see
it's like i'm kissing [ __ ] burt
reynolds here
all right so when i went home i had to
devise a master plan operation mustache
removal
i like this girl
way too much and she was still very hot
with the ex
even with the stash
but i needed a way to get rid of it
because i wanted to help her out while
also helping myself all right now this
is why i picked this one here
listen to this guy he's got a gorgeous
[ __ ] woman
everything about her is perfect except
she has a [ __ ] mustache
now how the hell
do you bring it up to somebody that you
care about that they have a mustache and
is [ __ ] turning you off
there's no way to do that without
sabotaging the relationship or
or really hurting the other person
the only way to do that is if you just
completely don't give a [ __ ] about the
other person and just say hey you know
if there's any way you could uh
you know
i don't i may not have [ __ ] saved
well this is what he did then this was
genius
he said uh since we just started seeing
each other i didn't want to come out and
say bae
babe you shaved today
seemed a little self-conscious that it
is so i didn't want to tell her and
embarrass or anything like that i needed
a way to remove this stash without being
involved
hence i did what needed to be done
listen to this [ __ ] brilliant
conspiracy i called my trustworthy buddy
who was playing hockey in canada at the
time and told him i needed him to do me
a solid dude
i filled him in on the situation and he
was willing to help me out since he had
a weird random canadian number at the
time i gave him my chick's number and
told him to text her and simply say you
have a mustache
i ordered him to say nothing else
and not to respond under any
circumstances
he texted me back about 20 minutes later
and said mission complete
so this [ __ ] lady
just to get you caught up in case you're
confused here with my reading
she gets a random text from a canadian
number
out of nowhere that just says you have a
mustache
i can't imagine your [ __ ] stomach
must have dropped
it's when he goes anyways he goes later
that night i met her at the bar and she
was looking extraordinarily sexy she
seemed that she seemed to have a little
pep in her step
i walked up to give her a kiss and i
looked above her lip and the peach fuzz
mustache was gone
clean and soft as a baby's bottom i was
very happy how it played out i held
myself up because that would have
bothered me and i helped her become even
sexier best part being she had no idea
that i orchestrated that mission i
didn't have to talk about it bring it to
her attention and hurt her feelings or
anything like that i just had a broad
with a clean upper lip thought i'd share
go [ __ ] yourself
dude that is absolute genius and now i
just got paranoid because i said what's
[ __ ] school you went to and all that
[ __ ] i hope you don't get in trouble but
if you somehow your woman is listening
to this
a guy does something like that not
because he's being a dick it's because
he cares for you
and uh
we don't know how to uh
we we don't have those skills
how do you tell somebody that
there's no way to do it
i think what he did was genius nobody
got [ __ ] hurt you felt great about
yourself
he cared about you enough sweetheart in
case you're listening
that he came up with the plan that you
know if he put it in another
area he could have like whacked jfk
so there you go he came up with an
enigma wrapped up in a riddle however
that [ __ ] that goes
and uh and you look even better
i would hope somebody would do that for
me
all right girlfriend in fantasy league
hey bill love the podcast
thank you i've been in a fantasy
football league for 10 years it was
started by one of my best friends and
has been the same 12 guys for a decade i
don't even know how bands have put
i don't even know bands that have been
together that long so this year my buddy
who started the league decided to boot
out two lifelong members in favor of his
girlfriend
and the girlfriend
of a friend of ours
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
did those other two guys who got booted
did they do anything
mean if he was gonna add the ladies why
did those other two guys have to leave
wow all right okay well i'm sucked into
this story he said i immediately called
[ __ ] and said point blank to his
face
if she wasn't sucking your dick then she
wouldn't be in the league oh dude
that right there is a game changer you
can't say what if he marries this woman
always there's a rule for you guys
always be careful what you say about the
woman your guy is with because you never
[ __ ] know
you never know and i'm sure there's some
listeners that have stories and if you'd
like to contribute them to the podcast
where uh you know what's even [ __ ]
worse
is when
your buddy
he says [ __ ] up [ __ ] about the girl
you know about what a [ __ ] she is in
bed and she's [ __ ] his brains out but
blah blah blah blah
and tells you all these these
details
and then the jackass ends up falling for
and then he has to [ __ ] break up with
you because he's not going to break up
with her because every time he looks at
you he thinks oh
you know he knows how this girl my
future wife sucks my dick you know
anyways plowing ahead
he's trying to defend his decision by
saying
she at least knows a little about sports
dude this is awful
this guy wasn't raised right man this is
just this is [ __ ] terrible
he said the fact of the matter is that
she is from new york and knows who the
jets are that's the extent of her
football knowledge he thinks i'm
overreacting you're not overreacting
he didn't ask anybody else you've had 12
for the last 10 years and he just
removed two of the original band members
dude this isn't even funny this is right
this is really upsetting to me
he thinks i'm overreacting but i think
of it the same scenario if you had
if you have one night a year to have a
guys night with your buddies and then
you get to the bar you see that your
friends has invited his girlfriend
to guys night exactly he even told me
that she she's the one who asked if she
could join which obviously to me means
he had no intentions of inviting her but
when he was backed into the corner his
balls shut up into his throat
and he couldn't say no exactly
it's not just a fantasy league but a
clear indication that she's going to
slowly start chipping away at everything
else in the rest of his life exactly in
summation his girlfriend wanted in and
he crumbled and said yes
am i reading too much into this am i
overreacting i'd like to know because
he's getting pissed at me for being
pissed at him absolutely not sir
everything that i was gonna tell you you
already know and you wrote in this email
okay you ran down the mat you went off
the little [ __ ] springy board you hit
the [ __ ] hobby horse you did your
little [ __ ] mary lou lit and flip and
you stuck the landing
you get a perfect 10 on that one sir you
are 100 right
you know what you want my move would be
i would start my own fantasy week
all right
and i would invite
everybody else in that [ __ ] league
well i wouldn't do that because that's
that's a chick move
make people decide
now this is why i wouldn't be as harsh
with him and just be like no dude what
you did was absolute [ __ ] and i
guarantee you i would tell him that
she's going to start chipping away with
you at your life
your balls are up in your throat
um but that's gonna end your friendship
with them
but here's the deal dude there are other
fantasy football leagues
to join
all right and uh that that's one of
those ugly things about
that chapter of guys lives
after um college
you know when you went to grade school
together or you met him and called guys
in college or whatever but you guys have
this unbelievable bond
like you went to [ __ ] war together
um
if one of your friends
is a [ __ ]
you know he has a he has a chance of
meeting somebody who's going to splinter
the group
you know and this isn't an anti-woman
thing this is more like an anti-pussy
guy kind of thing where uh
you know there are controlling
suffocating people on both sides men and
women and i know that there's women
listening and they've
one of their best girlfriends started
dating some [ __ ] overbearing
insecure douchebag guy and the first
thing they do is they cut them off from
their friends and then it's the
co-workers then the friends and then
their family
they stick them under a [ __ ]
little glass or something so uh
yeah you know what dude the worst the
sad thing is you're gonna lose a couple
of friends sometimes that happens and uh
you just have to be content about it and
you know and i think it's really
important for men and women
to have men only and women only social
events
that they can go to once a week or a
couple times a month
and just hang out with the fellas and
hang out with the ladies and just
whatever
i think it's really really healthy
it gives you something to look forward
to
it gives you a place where you can just
vent
about your anything you [ __ ] want
in in a group of people that 100 percent
is going to understand and you have to
worry about hurting anybody's feelings
or offending on anybody i think it's
true it's really really [ __ ] healthy
and this guy's [ __ ] with that
and uh and he didn't put it to a vote
what is he the grand poobah of this [ __ ]
i don't know there's so many ways you
can go with that to spending depending
on how much you want to stir up the pot
you guys should put it to the vote
this would be great put it to a vote
dude have this be like your arab spring
but with a fantasy football league and
just vote that [ __ ] out
and then you become the dictator and you
move into the palace
how about that
whatever dude you're 100 right i would
just i would choose my words a little
more carefully um
don't say that he didn't have the balls
just say listen
this was something that we did together
for 12 years
and uh
i'm really disappointed and shocked that
you made this big a move and removed two
other members and didn't include anybody
else
in it
i don't think that it was done right and
i think we should put this to a vote
that's what we should do
and if he gets mad and he starts yelling
don't lose your cool just keep stating
your opinion calmly
and you know if he's going to be a [ __ ]
about it let him be a [ __ ] about it and
i would actually for your own health
dude she only thinks she knows is the
jet she's going to be like wait a minute
who's that oh my god i don't know
anything she's gonna try to do that you
know that thing where women try to act
like they're dumb because they think
it's cute
you know what i would do sir i would
just cut your losses
just [ __ ]
don't know the more i think about it the
more annoyed i'm getting this rule in my
[ __ ] day and i'm not even in it i
don't even like fantasy football all
right banker [ __ ]
all right billy boy uh so have you heard
about these greedy [ __ ] at goldman
sachs that was kind of a national story
what did they do something else he said
they cornered a large share of the
market in aluminum
and then bettered on the futures of
illumine with the price going up sounds
illegal
it is but of course those stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] found a loophole in the law the
loophole is that 25 tons of aluminum is
supposed to leave the warehouse every
day however the law doesn't specify
where it had to go
so they would just send it to another
warehouse of theirs and technically it
didn't leave the warehouse
in the new york times article they
interviewed people who previously worked
at these warehouses they would jokingly
send each other messages and say hey get
hey get that shipment of aluminum
but really they were just transferring
it to an adjacent warehouse
uh i i this is i don't even get what the
[ __ ] going on here of course goldman
sachs has recently posted its largest
quarter profit of over 2 billion
when we take these bankers out into the
street and just shoot them all joking
aside this [ __ ] is insider trading and
they should be prosecuted but we know
that won't happen
uh p.s know you're busy for a while but
when are you coming back to atlanta
uh i actually don't know
i don't know why i'm coming back to
atlanta
you know what that's one of those things
i should have read that 20 times in a
row and learned
what exactly is going on i think this is
basically how they get away with it is
that there's too many people like myself
that don't even understand what was
going on there
all that stuff betting on futures i
don't even understand what any of that
means
i was just in the stock market long
enough to realize like hey
i don't know what the [ __ ] going i'm
i'm i i basically felt like i was
standing at a crap table
uh
i put my money on a crap table in a and
i wasn't even in the casino
you know i was in a different state and
then i was calling somebody else up
going hey how's the game going
you know i saw a couple of the stats at
the bottom of the screen and i can't
even read them
i don't even know if the game's even
being played
that's what i can't get past about
everybody listening to this podcast you
don't you don't have any of the money
that you earn every week
you don't have any of it
you ever think about that
it's a number on a piece of paper you
take it to the bank and then they stick
that number in your atm then
occasionally you go to the atm they give
you a piece of paper that is only worth
something because everybody says it's
worth something but you really have
nothing of value what you have is the
piece of paper that's uh
part of the life
so that that is the genius of all of
this [ __ ] and through penalties and fees
and taxes and all that crap they get you
even further removed or you have to
invest it
you know why do i have to [ __ ] invest
you can't yeah i don't know
you don't get anything you don't get
anything of [ __ ] value
the only thing that has value is the lie
and as long as the lie continues
i mean isn't this the month where we go
to raise the debt ceiling every [ __ ]
year eventually that wave is going to
crash
um
i don't know i hope when the wave
crashes that all races and all economic
levels
somehow put down their differences and
they all come together and we just start
walking towards gated communities
all right
there you go
how much you stealing that you have to
live
behind a gated community they live
they're sitting there acting like
they're they're afraid that we're gonna
steal their [ __ ] it's like you got your
[ __ ] by stealing from us
all right anarchy
sorry
all right where am i going here
the next one
low libido girlfriend
uh
all right hey bill i've been with my
current girlfriend for two years
and we've had our ups and downs
ups and downs relationship wise
but even at the lowest points we still
get back together
okay
is there a reason you get back together
is it because you actually love this
girl are you just lonely and don't want
to go through the pain of a breakup
uh the problem is at this point in the
relationship it seems like i'm the only
one interested in sex maybe it's just a
man thing or how long we've been dating
but she's in her 20s and i'm 31
and we have the sex life
of a middle-aged married couple once a
month or once every three weeks at best
she generally responds to my advances
with disinterest or at worst annoyance
do you think there is any ways to change
this
are we just
not sexually compatible go [ __ ] yourself
well my gut tells me the relationship is
over and it's been over
um oh you said ups and downs you didn't
say that you broke up
i ran into that um
yeah you need to sit down and talk to
her
and just say listen uh
i just want to talk about her sex life
i feel like it's almost non-existent and
when i
try to get something going with you i
feel like you're uh
like i just completely
turn you off
you know did i do something
and if in general if you're just not
into me anymore just let me know because
i'm 31
and uh i should probably try and find
someone who finds me remotely attractive
when you think so
it's kind of what i'm looking for in
life somebody who actually
gives a flying [ __ ] that i'm shaking my
dick in their face
huh
see like right there look you just look
down
just a mere mention of me shaking
my [ __ ] in your feet no sorry
yeah that's what i would do
do you think there's any change of this
or are we just not sexually compatible
that this is all like all relationship
[ __ ] is communication you have to sit
down first when you want to communicate
relationship what i've learned the best
thing to do is sit down with yourself
first
all right
driving in the car get all the yelling
out scream at the windshield yeah and
what the [ __ ] i'm sitting there i went
over to your brother's house the other
day and what do i get you know just
scream and get it all out
and then when you get all of that out
then you just do some self analysis and
you try to break down the anger and be
like what am i really
upset about
you know
what do i feel right now i feel like i'm
not being heard i feel this i feel that
and then what you then you had to have
this game plan
okay even if you got to make like a set
list like a [ __ ] comedian and you
just write down what you're feeling and
the points that you want to get out
draw a smiley face at the end of it to
remind yourself to not get angry because
you're going to start the conversation
this works for both men and women you're
going to start the conversation so the
other person is caught off guard so they
didn't get a chance to scream at the
windshield so they might start screaming
at you so your point your your
main thing is
not to
join in and have the whole thing
escalate you just want to be heard
all right so if you in an adult way just
tell them what you're feeling without
insulting them
it's always good for the relationship
even if the relationship [ __ ] comes
to an end
uh you're just pressing fast forward
through a bunch of pain
so there you go so i would just sit down
with her and just say yeah i just feel
like i repulse you to the point that i'm
you know i feel hesitant to even even
try to make a move on you
what's the deal
you know see how that works out all
right road head accident
hey bill i took my lady
out to a nice steakhouse for our
anniversary we had an awesome night the
food was expensive but [ __ ] great we
picked out and after it was all over we
left
we then went
and seen a movie
i don't know if that's a typo sir but i
[ __ ]
i know guys like you we went out we had
all this meal and we went out we seen a
movie
and had two hours
to let our stomachs settle i'm surprised
you didn't fall asleep i would have if i
had a giant steak dinner i would have
got the itis
anyways then after we left the theater
we locked eyes in the car and we
immediately wanted the [ __ ]
jesus dude you're killing it steak
dinner movies now you're gonna you know
you got a woman who wants to jump on
your dick god bless you
america
uh so i threw the neon
into drive and floored it towards home
however she had the amazing idea to give
me some road head before we got home
being a dude i had my dick out before
she even got situated of course
after a while of her doing this she
started to gag
being a dude i was thinking oh yeah she
can't even handle this dick jesus christ
this guy's sparing no details sorry
ladies
uh despite the fact that she had never
gagged before oh sorry i missed the the
self-deprecating
tag there
he said i was thinking she can't handle
this dick despite the fact she had never
gagged before
before i knew it
oh no
all right if you're squeamish people
just shut it off now
he goes i felt a wet sensation on my
balls
as i looked down i noticed that she had
thrown up all over my dick balls and
general crotch area
sorry
wow
here's the [ __ ]
she was mad at me
what the [ __ ] she was so upset and
embarrassed that's what it is right
there sir about
about it that she hasn't come over in
two weeks
why is she pissed she isn't the one that
had the cleanest steak da
right all right tell me what to do
um
i gotta tell you this she's being really
immature she's embarrassed
she's embarrassed
and
she's not being mature about this
where i mean it was a mutual thing
it's not like you grabbed her by the
back of the head and just slammed her
head down there you know
she was all about it
in fact
if i remember before i can get that
nightmare visual out of my head it was
her idea right
i mean when the [ __ ] whoever she had the
amazing idea to give me some head off
she's a trooper
you know this is what i would do
send her a card in the mail
all right
and just just tell it that you know
you miss her
i you don't view her any differently or
anything
and just just write something nice i'd
really like to uh
take you out for an ice cream even if
you do throw it up all of my dick and
balls later i think it'd be kind of uh
soothing you know it's the summertime
months and that crotch area can get a
little hot so i wouldn't mind a little
mint chocolate chip around the pubes
there
all right
leave out the last part
but
i don't just send her a nice car i
wouldn't even bring up the incident just
send her a nice card
something cute
nothing silly nothing [ __ ] overly
loving just something in the middle
you know what sir i think we actually
found a new niche
for hallmark
they got to have one where there was
something sexually weird happened
and the other person is embarrassed and
the other person doesn't judge him and
wants him back you could have those
cards
let's see if i can come up with one here
that actually rhymes
uh
dear lady you got a little shady
i still love you
i don't know you puked on my dick and
balls i don't know how to [ __ ] get
somewhere in there
uh wrap ups okay that's a podcast for
this week everybody uh once again i feel
absolutely horrible that people actually
came out to that uh
to the [ __ ] el paso show i don't know
what happened i don't know if you missed
an email or what but it seemed like
enough people showed up that the ball
got dropped somewhere i announced it
here on the podcast
um
i don't know anyways
my apologies
wrap ups okay now that the show's over
don't forget to support our sponsors
this is really important
this is how i make money on this thing
and i don't have to charge anybody [ __ ]
uh
once again get started with the free
30-day trial of e-voice e-voice gives
you a toll-free number
go for your local number so you can make
business calls from anywhere and always
sounds like you're at the office uh
right now go to evoice.com
enter the promo code bill for your 30
day free trial that's evoice dot com
promo code bill or go to the podcast
page billboard.com and click on the
evoice banner uh support this podcast
get an extended free trial of hulu plus
when you go to the podcast page
billboard.com and click the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com bill that's
huluplus.com bill that's podcast for
this week
uh once again my apologies to everybody
who went down
to the show and i'll pass so i feel
horrible about it
everybody else go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great week that's it i'll talk to you
later
where's the stop button there it is